foreign
oh
okay
little pasta
um
we have many and you remember
that's feminine yes that when you have
one it's masculine and when you have
many it becomes feminine
oh
we are going to prepare five
cinque cortioli five portions
okay the proportions the proportion are
very very very simple
okay
if you don't have it at home you can
just pound them
something
so what i want with the mandolin
i want
them in in different sizes so some of
them
you want to very very very fine follows
like powder
and then you want to chop some of them a
little bit thicker and maybe you can
leave a handful
that's not chopped at all but you can
put on the top kind of decoration
nice okay then we need
lemon zest
grapefruit
so the white part is bigger when you
when you are well you use this
to great
you really just want to stop at the very
surface of the yellow part
because the white part
okay
then we're going to add just a drop
of
vanilla
and
i forgot very important ingredient
wow
it's very very very easy
we want to leave the butter outside a
little bit because it really has to be
at room temperature right now it's too
hard
okay
this is a little bit more
i was thinking that
no no no microwave is going to be too
warm so leave it here and it's going to
be the last ingredient because first you
will mix
all the dry ingredients
then the eggs the last thing the butter
and as i told you you don't want to make
it it's not like pizza that you really
have to need it
no you really just want to just barely
put things together it has to be very
loose
okay and then we will we will put just
directly the crumbles we just let them
fall on the baking pan
quanta
um
well because if you like the contrast
like
sweet salty dolce salato right
but not everybody likes it and it's not
in the traditional recipe but if you
like it then you can add pizzico a pinch
pizza
picollo tea just a drink
okay
now we're using this
as baking pans that's fine but you can
also use like baking
sheets it's not really important
and you can either cover them
yes until you've scarred every spot on
the left
and then you will help yourself
okay
not the subject but the grammar
um
really very delicate you don't want to
make the dough no it's virtual ornaments
with a lot of bridge on it so it has to
remain very crumbly and the idea is that
you want the thickness
of something from
one
to two and a half centimeters
if it's thinner it bakes faster
thicker takes a little bit longer
it smells so good yeah
together and then you will like save it
like this and
spread it
okay
less than half
this is the way look here
oh
traditionally you do not use a knife to
cut it
you just break it you use it yeah
it's probably a little too hot right now
but usually you wait for it from the
cooler and then you break it with your
hands if you want you can try to
transfer it to a plate and then you get
a cooler
and you can break it or you can try to
breathe
now it's hot so it's crumbling even more
than usual when it gets dry it becomes
very hard sometimes it's really awesome
so we have a lunch and you see yeah we
put a lot of butter but usually you
don't eat as much
you